Mach weiter Janos Neha Ali Progresso Gina
Oh Holloway siehe Deutsch hallo Deutsch
hallo hallo ein Deutscher ein demütiger Beloit
hallo einfacher Deutscher das wenn ja ich
mehr
hallo wie sie jede Banane
das Mexiko Visum von morgen gehört mir jagen mein
Glück
hallo du lebst unter einem Gesetz  iijima
hallo hallo kaufst du durch die dusche
denn ich habe oft ihre ideen sind
streitigkeiten irvine hat nicht online gesehen steep
endian für den verlust einiger besitz des fc
lang auf drei läufen des einfachen deutschen
edels nur feuchtigkeitsstock besitzt
ölvideo  so hühnchen und als ich
sie auf lautsprecher gab Hubert stumm dann kommen
alle videos wöchentlich strenge gansan
versagt aus thailand erinnere mich an meine
meinung Kamel Kenia übliche ASIMO miscomi sonst
Tansania und Premierminister laut
ishcomer Alex Vietnam ist komatös dann
wer ist das es war Santiago  in jedem
Kommentar Argentinien
Ich komme aus Syrien und lebe jetzt in
Deutschland Brasilianisch Eslint Hamas Taiwan
E-Commerce Rumänisch Sie kommen aus Boulder
Colorado, um dort Medizin zu machen  in Martina
Windish kommt aus Südafrika, aber
ich bin in Dubai geboren und aufgewachsen Penta
Maki einmal komme ich LC öffnen
Indonesien Mazedonien
Kolumbien gut ich meine San Jose
Kalifornien
Jocelyn stolperte über jeden Kommentar als
Hong Kong Bahasa Indonesien ja jeder, den ich
sehe, interessiert mich nicht  USA Kanada ein
anderes Houston Texas wie die Okarina
jedes Al's Nigeria sogar in Melbourne auf
Italienisch Ich würde sechziger Jahre gegen ärgerlich
aus dem Magazin sein, aber sah mir wirklich pro Wort das
heißeste Sommerklima Rhenium Algodones
an, dann haben Sie
die Amish ein Alter in einer Dimension  D-
Anleihen und Team sind von Vision Loiter D
wöchentliche Öfen und Food-Event
Deanna Risin Tante oder Kiana am ersten
Pfand auf Yuba unter der Lenin-Tundra coole
Kinder und Göttinnen pro Tochter
tanzt auch wie erwähnt in einem
Ereignis, das allein Videos am ersten
Pfandrecht besitzt  über Dinah des Effendi Asiana, wenn
ASEAN unter dem Land auftaucht,
George Leonard Haifa ist die Wochenzeitung der TSA
Sophia unter ihrer Figur sie ke  pt auf
Eigentum wünschte, Sie hätten kein Haus für
Darlin Automotive auf See gehabt Onan auf
diesem [ __ ] in meinen Augen andere Dimension
entdecken Sie das Heimische auf Steroiden
dann verschmolz er es ist agasshi Kangana
fünfzehn Andaz Summen über unsere Ölkurve
arbeitete an Gerät macht einen Zylinder  Sheila
schüttelt Assistenzgeschenk von Antia,
es ist ein Zeichen für Ausländer, eine Allianzwelle,
und Allah sagt, ein Amerika-
Dino in beiden ist flügge geworden
De Anza hat sie gesagt, ich will
Deutsch lernen und wirklich gut in Deutsch sein, damit
ich keine
Angst davor habe, Deutsch zu sprechen oder
Risiken einzugehen, oder ich weiß nicht, wie heute
beim Drucken, das war erschreckend,
ich will nur
Um mich sicherer zu fühlen, werde ich mich beim Bau eines
Planetoiden beteiligen, während ich in Deutschland
Studiomonitore bearbeite, also habe
ich Physik studiert, und ich denke, für mich
wäre es ein Traum, in Deutschland zu studieren
vor allem weil es so toll ist dort zu
leben weil es so eine tolle
kultursprache hat ich habe deutsch gelernt
weil deutsch eine der
schönsten sprachen der welt ist deutsch
ist ein sehr wichtiges land für das
richtige wort es eröffnet mir auch die
möglichkeit es zu lernen  ein besserer Job
und damit die Möglichkeit,
meine Familie besser zu unterstützen. Problem ist,
als Fila zu werfen, während Fila den
sozialen
Wasserdruck in den Knien löst.
Ich weiß, dass der Unterricht ein Ärgernis ist
- rock in this sir Besson Meine
Motivation Deutsch zu lernen ist,
weil ich am wichtigsten
bin, mit meinem Schwager kommunizieren zu können
, der Deutsch ist, was
es so viel interessanter macht
Trocknen Sie das Gas, das
entschieden hat, dass er noch nicht an seinem
Problem gemangelt hat,
also ist Scott der Traum von Alice und ein anständiger
Schwung, was dann einer war, von dem ich dachte, dass
Ferguson ich immer lernen wollte  n York,
vielleicht, weil meine Familie nach Brasilien kam
[Musik]
Ich bin zum Deutschen gegangen, weil ich
Musik studieren und auf Deutsch vermarkten möchte,
und meine Motivation, Deutsch zu lernen, ist
mein Großvater, er ist deutscher
Muttersprachler, und jedes Mal erinnere ich ihn daran, dass
ich  lerne deutsch es macht ihm große
freude also danke für deine videos und
corvina mr.  Griffis Deutsch Lenin naja ich
sehe einen Gärtner der früher zu hohen Kufen
Orgelstift bei Bill Maher Brücken heimische
Äpfel waren - ein vater denkst du schon mal
an diese Angewohnheit feilenfisch ausweichen ein
aggressor hier unser vater ist mein name
motivation pseudo lernenin ist verdammt feucht
ist  in deutschland steuere
und besitze einen beißer
ow ich mag philosophie auf twitter
porosität gemein auch berühre einen
schäle mich nicht käse freud - königreich
kindergarten net die ostham erde
mutter monster bummel durch spa inspiration
geht weiter ehrlich parker neues englisch
gleich das einzige
ina  unterwäsche spanisch von ihm spaß spaß
spielzeug in meiner anlage und eigentlich einer meiner
dienste wird sein in dein land
nach deutschland zu kommen und war dort
letztes jahr als arzt bin ich
für ein paar wochen auf ein austauschprogramm gegangen und das hat so
viele deutsch gemacht  Freunde und ich würde mich
freuen, mit ihnen mehr in ihrer Muttersprache Turban sprechen zu können oder mit ihnen in Kontakt zu treten.
Ich bin Deutsch lernen gegangen, weil
ich Geschichte hier Platz haben möchte  Aling in
Deutschland über Foremans Vicki bekommt
Gavin ein schweres Lied singen Dämonen sind ungefüttert
Japan Jim Früchte Weißes Haus Ärger
üblich, ja, erhob sich weiter sugyeong
Saloons of Inversion Huberman DBMS ist
die deutsche Frau für Allens unter
den Epsilon-Medien ein wöchentliches Gespräch mit Viet
Deutschland  von unbezahlten Picenum
glückseligen Informationen über die
Warnung von East One Herb Nischen und Abstimmung
ja nicht natürlich fertiges Angebot Android
Salon Denim und Effekt hing Azimut auf
einem Server an von unserer Eichmann-Motivation,
wenn Bereich klicken Sie auf Kent
in uns MIT und ehrlicher Cent auf Mann
auf  über Westen Glavin über Oktagon ja
dieses Jahr bei Xugong konsultiert, also
bauen auf Service Orson als die
Affinität zum süßen Gefühl in der Höhe
die Alben auf erfahrenen wollen in den F-
Sämlingen ab und fühlen es in den Höhen von
Amazon vergessen, die für mein Haus
wunderbare Eisweltohren besser zugewiesen sind
Richtschnur lief auf der Schwester aus schöner
Kleidung als ein Flug von ihm und Debye
auf noch Kugel J  anos dann kann es de sehen
mindestens eine Zeile und glänzend
Janusz hier bin ich bei Austin's meine Einheit
von E-Mail Steve jemals gemeinsam haben einen
geben mir Nüsse von sehenin mir sehen von Anna
Yano gegeben sind keine Minen ja könnte
keines meiner Augen sein dieser Nenner für einen
anderen  ist gemein du brauchst o weit Nilo weit
für Leben
yay Tante Peggy veena ist Jaffe Halevy die
Affäre - Karina ist hafiz' Dean nächste
Avena ist MZ Modi nein es ist gut ich mache eine
Erwähnung ich kann nicht Konfession sein ich
habe Licht und ina unter a gelassen  Folder Shift
Shrim ist das per E-Mail,
okay, gegeben ein AM / FM-Faust,
ciao auf Ja, gegeben eine Nummer sechs, ist
Himalaya und Gonski, ein bigotter
Gutschein Wow, geben Sie anonym Eva, Mist,
Diego, eine Kunst, nur
Najiba, Murad, auf Cabina,
kein Monoi, ist Cal-Einkommen  nur für Licht
lass uns studieren lass uns studieren lass uns einen
Bösewicht auf die Nase nehmen ist charmant
Charmaine Helsing Lippenschlag eine Geräuschszene
über Gartenoase verstehe ja
und sage, dass ich mich vom Sex fühle, auch nachdem
ich über ein Geräusch gesehen
habe, dass ich ein Video habe nicht '  T  E-Mail-Huhn Eigenes Spielzeug
Ich lerne, also habe ich nicht Sky Coil bestehen
Schule oft, dass ich vorbeikomme Ich glaube, es
war Schüttelgeräusch in einer E-Mail auf lautes
Geräusch Einsteinium Skype-Coil-Fäustlinge in
Yonghwa auf dem Stand Verity von einem Klavier und
Sudan voraus und Sue si Lang  Vincennes über
eine Frau als Fußsache Mord an
Vivians Geiselbiss Xion eigener
Flickenbruch über Folie auf Xia Kenan albern
auf einem L'Enfant
DJ-Medium sind Tabs für Eylem über Eisen
darunter Deons andere Videos gefunden
, die Veganer für die Wiener Konvention machen auf
und  Sheerness beendet Samia Mochilas
hat weder Videos für Phonons wie
Disney auf O Muhammad noch ein [ __ ]
für verschiedene Gerätetelefone Anna Shona,
ja, und sie hat keinen Moment o feuchtere Diamanten,
Jesus, ein wunderbares Gähnen, und wir
haben in letzter Zeit keine
Talia-Farmtierspielzeuge  Vietnam und
yappin und Tyrande in was sind in Mexiko
sie haben einige fragen meine HTC-Telefone in den
sozialen Netzwerken und derzeit könnte
sie uns oft schaden
eingeladen
zu oft
danke für Inseln für ich werde
Organisationskollegen sogar unterstützen das ist der
Iran ist ein poetischer McLeish markiert, damit ich
nicht in einen Herrn miaue.  Nelson Lima kommt
mit uns, welches Gericht hoffnungsvoll wird,
und er fragt oft mein in Unzen erwähntes
Team, das er auf unserem Knopf gemacht hat
[Musik]